hmm let's see let me make some
first name
[Music]
uh let's see maybe last name
oh just oh oh hello i'm just making some
json here now i've made this json object
question comes to mind if that's the
format i love to work in what is the
best data store to handle json objects
hello my name is jamil spain brand
technical specialist with the u.s
financial services market today i want
to talk through when making that
decision not the front end not the back
end but for the database layer in your
application architecture if you love
working with json which database of
choice should you use today's topic is
mongodb
being that choice now as a technologist
often when we evaluate technology we
ought to have some type of criteria to
make our decisions against here i have
my chosen three that i like to do when
it comes to evaluating technology the
flexibility how easy easy is it to
implement and also at some point once we
start having fun behind the keyboard we
got to consider the deployment aspect
here
i've already started here with the json
object so as you can see and guess
is great for storing
nosql data structures meaning it's not
you know built to be i don't have to
define the structure up front i can take
a json object a document that really has
no structure
any number of fields and it's great to
store that then it also is an in memory
data store
so all the objects that i store are
located in memory processed there which
means i have relatively easy access
to get to those as well these json
documents can be any kind of size here
one caveat that i have learned from
working with this and leveraging
to store my documents here is be
conscious of sometimes we have a
tendency with json
to not have a set number of fields and
that can become a problem you may want
to make placeholders for null values or
define some type of consistency here as
well
one other great feature that i've
noticed is if i were to add a longitude
latitude to my json object is
great for querying doing geospatial
queries against these data sets as well
so if i wanted to make my own
type of let's say a food delivery
service and i wanted to determine which
locations were closest to you if i have
the users
me spain here
actual longitude latitude coordinates i
could compare that against the other
json documents that may also include the
same type of information here as well
all right i think we've covered this
let's put a check mark next to
flexibility
here as well now when it comes to
implementation yes you got to make sure
that all the sdks are available are
there any limitations that you have to
account for so of course there is uh
javascript there's java
golang there's pretty much
all the the value pairs are there that's
the popular languages are are there for
you to use and easy examples client
libraries to actually access this as
well so not a consideration uh from
there let's talk about deployment for a
second after i do that check markle
implementation here therefore deployment
you can set up mongodb relatively
i want to say easily but it does there
are easy ways to facilitate whether it's
on containers or
maybe on your own linux servers you can
set up an easy instance without security
very easy to play with so for
development i would say yes it's very
easy to set up a single instance
and prove out
how easy it is to implement into your
architecture whether you're architecting
for web or mobile and what you're
working with
and for production purposes once you get
that exciting architecture set up here
you will have the ability it works off
the same what i like to call main and
secondary models so you have a main node
that you publish to or interact with and
it can do the replication
to those secondaries
so scaling that way on more of a
horizontal scale to meet the demand of
your
actual architecture there so that can
really be useful if you want it to be
your primary database
to function with and as we know json is
becoming a pretty popular standard to to
work with your data structures there
so we'll do the check mark there
so hopefully it's been useful there's
much much more with just touching the
surface here
but i want you to definitely go out to
mongodb.org and look out for more
information thank you for your time
if you have questions please drop us a
line below and if you want to see more
videos like this in the future please
like and subscribe